today we're going to create an avatar
that looks and moves like me We Begin by
smiling into the camera
I love to smile
smiling's my favorite and breathing
gently for a short second
as this wet breathing looks like
I'm Joanna Stern and I'm excited to host
this video
no I am the real Joanna okay so I clone
myself kinda
howdy why well the latest AI tools that
generate text and images already make it
hard to tell the difference between
what's real and what's fake what's
coming next with AI generated voice and
video is going to blur the lines even
more so I came up with a challenge
can I replace myself with AI for the day
yes I came up with four challenges to
see if AI me could Sub in for real me so
realme had more time for me things
or at least that's how I wanted it to go
so a little creeped out that I'm looking
at a frozen Joanna okay let's do this
before we get into the challenges let's
talk about my AI Avatar which was made
by a startup called Synthesia
make my avatar at a professional studio
in New York the company recorded me
doing a series of head movements I feel
like about the eye doctor okay and
reading through a rather odd pre-written
script positive thinking will help you
believe in yourself and fill you with
self-esteem and confidence after that I
headed to an audio Studio where I
recorded another script for about an
hour my name is Joanna Stern and I
hereby consent to this audio recording
to create a custom voice The company
took that all and used it as training
data and ran it through their AI neural
networks
hello Joanna you don't mind if I call
you Joanna do you okay so the voice
isn't the best a tool called 11 Labs
produce something better after my
producer Kenny uploaded two hours of my
previous recordings
I am the real Joanna I am the real
Joanna I am the real Joanna both
Synthesia and 11 Labs work similarly
type in anything and AI Joanna just says
it right back Synthesia is aimed at
companies that want to make internal
videos
it charges at least one thousand dollars
to create a custom avatar creating a
voice clone with 11 Labs is five dollars
a month challenge one phone calls I
happen to have a call scheduled that day
with Evan Spiegel the CEO of snap the
company recently released my AI a chat
bot within the popular app hey Evan it's
Joanna do you worry that if we chat with
AI all day we'll stop talking to our
real friends
definitely know what we've been seeing I
think that's one of the real benefits of
our sort of testing and learning
approach here so far I think if anything
it's going to become a conversation
enhancement and improve the way uh you
know that people communicate with their
friends and family did you think by any
chance that my question to you was
generated by an AI voice
you know
the the
serious today even my own sister was
pretty fooled when I called her about
her dead fish
hey Jules I just heard about swimmy
dimmy and I wanted to let you know how
sorry I am for your loss did you think
it was me at first yes then no like it
sounds it's obviously exactly like you
but
just with the fact that like it doesn't
pause for talking back challenge one
pass
challenge to create a tick tock I asked
chatgpt to write a tick tock script in
the voice of Joanna Stern about an
obscure iOS 16 tip the hardest thing was
getting Chachi BT to write the truth it
just made stuff up
finally I got a good one although the
writing certainly was not very me I
pasted the script into Synthesia put a
green screen behind my avatar and
exported it while The wsj Tick Tock team
edited I
I was pretty impressed with the final
tick tock tick tock fam it's Joanna
Stern your iOS wizard today we're
unearthing the Hidden World of back tap
gestures I love that I did not have to
shoot this he did not have to put on
nice clothes do my hair do my makeup
say these lines but Tick Tock was less
impressed they picked up on the fact
that the Avatar never moves its arms
that the mouth movements don't always
match the audio and that there's little
facial expression Synthesia has already
started to improve a lot of this in beta
versions of its avatars look I can nod
my head
challenge too
fail
Challenge 3 Bank biometrics
of asking security questions some banks
use your voice to confirm it's you
before transferring you to a customer
service rep this call will be monitored
and recorded and your voice may be used
for verification please speak your first
and last name followed by your mailing
address
Joanna Stern
Mrs Nikki with Chase credit card
services it worked she's confirmed the
voice and put me straight through to a
service rep no additional questions
asked later in the day I asked our
intern slav to try to do his best
impression of me to see what would
happen
name followed by your mailing address
Joanna Stern
please enter the last three digits
printed on the signature panel on the
back of your card see in slav's case the
voice biometric system didn't buy it it
asked for further verification
when I reached out to Chase's
spokeswoman said
we use voice Biometrics along with a
variety of other methods to authenticate
customers who call us she added that to
complete requests customers must provide
additional information
Challenge three pass
challenge 4 video calls
I asked Chachi PT to generate some
generic meeting phrases and exported
videos of my avatar saying them then I
installed some software on my Mac to
pump that video into my Google meet
calls it sounds good oh you're muted
Joanna oh my God is this the real Joanna
yeah this looks like a fake it sounds
good she looks yeah what what is
happening hey everyone how did you know
that it wasn't me it looked like a
hologram version of you
okay
challenge four big fail
so what did we learn today we learned
that video clones aren't going to fool
anyone yet but AI voices are quite good
we also learned that while you could use
these to save time people could also
misuse them do I want to avoid going to
the studio some days yup do I fear
scammers using our voices to call Banks
or our families yep Synthesia says it
requires those creating avatars to give
verbal consent 11 Labs requires you
check a box saying you have permission
to use the voice and the company says
it's capable of identifying its voices
if they are misused either way it means
we're all going to have to be on high
alert to tell the real versus the AI and
finally
stay human everyone
good luck I am inevitable